[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt's billig und
zwar ein ganz besonderes wenn nämlich
auf instagram verfolgte es auf dem blog
kanal dann wisst ihr dass wir dieses
jahr in antalya im urlaub fahren für
eine woche und dort habe ich so eines
der leckersten bendix überhaupt gegessen
willig ist ja eigentlich ein türkischer
begriff für teigwaren das gibt's in 1000
verschiedenen varianten aber wir haben
in der türkei
berdych mit käse gegessen mit sinn fein
die oft eigen ganz ganz ganz wie käse
und es gab noch in verschiedenen
ausführungen aber ich zeige euch heute
die klassische variante und ich habe
euch auch versprochen als ich das in der
story geteilt habe dass sich das rezept
liefern werde
und dafür müssen wir jetzt zuallererst
butter klären
die steht sie auch schon direkt am herd
mutter erklärt man indem man einfach
einen topf oder eine pfanne erwärmt ihr
dürft den top aber auch nicht zu heiss
machen denn du bist der butter brennt
auch mal schnell an das heißt langsam
erwärmung dann bildet sich schaum und
den muss man dann immer wieder
abschöpfen
[Musik]
so die mutter ist jetzt geklärt und ganz
wichtig warum haben wir das gemacht hier
befindet sich die molke und das bewirkt
dass butter eben super super schnell
anbrennen und das kann man bei diesem
rezept nicht gebrauchen denn gleich
kommt unser blick ja in den ofen bei
hoher temperatur und ihr soll sich das
jetzt auch nicht wegschmeißen könnte das
nehme ich gerne als geschmacksträger für
diverse rezepte und gerichte benutzen
und jetzt war ich folgendes ich lebe
meine auflaufform und werde zuallererst
yoga mit der butter schichten ich
schreibe euch übrigens alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben unten den li und wirkt
infobox so ich hab jetzt hier den kino-
und you've got von tante fanny das ist
ein ganz ganz feiner ich mach das mal
auf und zeige es euch meinen wenn man
hindurch gucken kann dann ist er perfekt
so mega fein und daher ist er perfekt
geeignet für dieses rezept und das ist
ja auch typisch türkisch und ihr könnt
aus dem tag sogar baklava machen also
der eignet sich nicht nur für herzhaftes
sondern auch für süßes rezepte und ich
schichte jetzt einfach mal und zeigt
euch dann im anschluss über das ganze
befüllen
[Musik]
die luftretter könnt ihr euch auch ganz
easy zurechtschneiden
eine auflaufform ist zb auch ein
bisschen länger und die ränder also
diese streifen die dürften nicht
wegwerfen wir brauchen wir gleich auch
noch und damit sie nicht austrocknen
weil wir dafür ein bisschen brauchen
einfach unter dieses papier legen was
auch in der verpackung schon mit drin
ist und ich möchte jetzt genieße
verpackung darüber
[Musik]
kommt mein letzter vorerst letzter joker
da drauf ich schneide den überschuss
immer ab und den überschüssen mogel ich
gleich noch mal unter daher ganz wichtig
dass er den jetzt nicht weg packt jetzt
ist es ganz wichtig ich habe das ganze
nämlich vorher ausprobiert und mir ist
aufgefallen dass man den ja vor
schneiden sollte denn wenn man ihn nach
dem backen in diese typischen rechtecke
schneidet das funktioniert nicht so gut
daher
schnappt euch jetzt ein messer und
schneidet jetzt quasi die kleinen
quadrate 1
[Musik]
natürlich kleine quadrate daraus
geschnitten ihr könnt die suppen oder so
groß machen hier möchte ich halte mich
also ein bisschen ans original und macht
er kleine quadrate daraus ein bisschen
butter noch obendrauf und jetzt kommt
unsere füllung täter am anfang gesagt
ihr könnt ein mega variiert nehme käse
war ich habe mich einfach in das rezept
mit käse verliebt als im urlaub war und
da geb ich glaube bereit ihr könntet
auch käsesorten müssen ihr können
da nehmen wir können unser renner nehmen
wenn ihr fettarmen käse nehmen ist
findet bei diesem rezept sollte man
jetzt nicht in die anfang fällt am käse
zu nehmen weil damit sowieso schon
butter drin und das schmeckt eigentlich
auch nur gut wenn ihre rechte
verteidigen these nimmt weil der dann
auch richtig schön schmilzt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den restlichen djk
beziehungsweise philo tag nochmal auf
dem t sind gegeben jetzt nicht noch mal
durchschneiden gleich ist die oberfläche
quasi der untere boden da wir das gleich
noch mal wenden werden jetzt kommt
erstmal in den vorgeheizten backofen 200
grad ober und unterhitze erst einmal für
15 bis 20 minuten ich sag das bewusst so
weil wir erst mal wollen dass die eine
seite bräunt wie das dann umdrehen und
dann einfach noch mal den rest bräunen
lassen und waadt euch gerne zwei bis
drei esslöffel von der geklärten butter
auf die brauchen wir gleich noch und
dann sehen wir uns gleich beim wenden
[Musik]
jetzt wird die restliche geklärte butter
mit milch und einem eifer quillt und das
geben wir jetzt auf die oberfläche und
dann kommt noch mal den ofen der ist ja
immer noch auf temperatur also immer
noch 200 grad ober und unterhitze für
weitere 15 bis 20 minuten erst richtig
schön goldbraun sein
[Musik]
ich freue mich einfach das ganze jetzt
so ist da drin der käse
der zieht richtig schön wenn das machbar
ist und das geniale dann einfach derzeit
ist halt super knusprig und der käse ist
hat noch mal so soft und das ist für
mich die perfekte kombination übrigens
wenn der einkauf ihr findet den frisch
von tiffany im kühlregal
es hat ja alles angefangen und
blätterteig ich glaube den kennt auch
jeder aber inzwischen noch nie so viele
weitere produkte und variationen und er
teilt fragen jetzt auch die ganzen
lieder ist ohne alkohol der ist aber
auch vegan falls veganer zuschauern gut
das rezept nicht vegan aber man kann ja
auch ganz viele andere sachen drauf
machen
ich würde jetzt sagen ich rufe den hamza
einfach man geht zu meiner rechnung dann
machen wir zusammen die tester so ich
bin gespannt was genau so schmeckt wie
im urlaub wirklich tätig doch mal rein
damit nichts fest aber es riecht schon
war schon richtig gut hier einfach
richtig gut
der frische viele teig knusprig aber so
die mitte ist so relativ deutlich im
positiven sinne und unten und omega
knusprig und haben auch diese käse
füllung feier ist 10 15 oder ist das ja
auch deswegen ist er so fein ähnlich wie
im bett aber nur von ganz vielen
schichten also ich finds so gut
abgesehen von der werbung läuft ich habe
gleich gemerkt dass es werbung das ist
ein sehr sehr lecker youth wirklich
stelle schon mehrere gästen auch so in
die richtung aber das finde ich heftig
er war halt sehr fein aber trotzdem sehr
fest ich habe das auch manchmal kommt
wirklich immer ganz stark darauf an
römischen reichs nie genau dann kriege
ich die krise und dann musste er das
alles abbekommen
das ist dabei bei diesem posten gehabt
kanisch stiller gerettet ja auch genau
da hatte ich einen kleinen zusammenbruch
weil das mal gerissen aber barßeler
könntet ihr auch mit diesem frischen
zutaten machen auch ich bin begeistert
macht unbedingt nach und kommt dann
zurück zum video und schreibt rein ließ
euch geschmeckt hat das geht auch mit
champignons förster ist doch nicht so
gerne champions kinderei machen
man kann pizza gewürzter reinhauen
hatten auch im urlaub oder pizza gehört
also weiß so richtig lecker ist bin ich
ja mal und tony jaa käse meisten tun
das ist typisch türkisch das ist die
klassische variante so einfach das
original
ok also ich verabschiede ich glaube ich
könnte mir das jetzt noch richtig schön
auf der couch und wünsche euch viel spaß
beim nachmachen hinterlasse diesem video
eindeutig nach oben wenn sich das wenn
euch das rezept gefallen hat und
natürlich ein kostenlos ab und verpasst
ihm solche gelernt ich auch so ich mache
mir das jetzt hier noch mal richtig
schön auf dem teller und so und wünsche
euch noch einen schönen tag bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]